one of the most important Concepts in
finance right now is the dollar
milkshake Theory my friend Brent Johnson
from Santiago Capital he's popularized
this idea and he deserves quite a bit of
credit for sticking with it through
historic inflation here's Brent
describing exactly how the dollar
milkshake Theory works and why you
should understand it with great detail
given the current environment you had uh
coined the milk the dollar milkshake
Theory and at the time I remember saying
to myself well the one thing that I'm
for sure is that that's great marketing
because I'll never forget that name uh
and maybe what we could do to kind of
start the conversation is just help
people understand like the high level
like what is this dollar milkshake
Theory and then we get into kind of
what's happened over the last two years
so in very simple terms and kind of the
reason I came up with the whole
description of the of the thesis as the
milkshake theory was I wanted to kind of
come up with just a really simple way to
explain it to people
and essentially what I think has
happened since the global financial
crisis in 2008 and you could probably
actually take it back even further than
that is that the global Central bank's
monetary authorities governments however
you want to define the the people that
kind of run the world for lack of a
better world have have flooded the
market with liquidity
um whether through QE or stimulus
programs or fiscal spending
and you know once we kind of got uh into
that kind of 10 years into that kind of
2018-2019 I thought we were set up for a
global Sovereign currency crisis and
sovereign debt crisis and I thought what
would happen was that all of that
liquidity that had been you know pushed
into the Global Financial system for
lack of a better word would be sucked up
into the United States and into the US
dollar and so
um I used kind of this analogy from this
this movie
um There Will Be Blood where this oil
Baron is uh you know negotiating with uh
the guy that owns the land right next to
him and the guy is trying to sell him
his land and he says I don't need to buy
your land all I got to do is stick up a
straw down into the ground and I can
drink your milkshake
um and that's kind of what I think is
going to happen uh it's not so important
who produces the QE what's more
important is who captures it and if you
look over the last couple years the
United States markets and the dollar
itself is captured I would say the most
of of the global growth you know the
dollar has risen versus a number of
global currencies despite all the
efforts to keep it down and so that's
that is in essence the milkshake Theory
now as I mentioned earlier that
explanation from Brent on the dollar
milkshake Theory sounds pretty obvious
today but Brent was talking about this
two three years ago and he's stuck with
this Theory even though we were seeing
High inflation and lots of people were
talking about the weakening US dollar a
key concept is to understand it's not
just about the strength or weakness of
the US dollar alone it's all about the
relative strength to other currencies
Brent nailed this one he deserves way
more credit for it and there's many
others that eventually saw what he saw
as well the Dollar's in a weird place
and the relative currencies around the
world are all falling at its feet the
dollar milkshake Theory looks genius
today but it always didn't look that way
kudos to Brent and I hope that you all
start paying attention to more of what
he's saying hey you did you like this
video great make sure you subscribe like
the video and see you next time